[Music]
tonight a fan with the YouTube handle
dude 30:35 thinks he caught a mistake he
says it happened during a recent
monologue in which I mentioned JetBlue
he said some dude was a smoking some
marijuana on a JetBlue flight and he
enjoyed the meal afterwards man was
arrested for smoking marijuana during a
JetBlue flight yeah
flight attendants became suspicious when
they noticed a passenger actually
enjoying the meal well that's impossible
because JetBlue doesn't serve meals they
only serve snacks it's interesting dude
3035 that your attention was snagged by
a joke involving marijuana and then BAM
we went in research the actual instance
that joke was based upon and it turns
out that JetBlue has secret video of the
customer at that moment check it out hey
business dude you got to try the taro
chips this is the best meal I've ever
had awesome
woman I'm confused what happened there
he's a tiny stoner know it that he
that's just a pre-existing condition you
have to buy into the fact first date
from Chicago the dudes really tiny so
small thing seemed like a meal no
explanation for why he's tiny you'll
just have to deal it doesn't look like
surveillance footage it's Shawn I sketch
everything about it's fun what you come
on this first day back